this man has just spent ten months three
weeks in one day in this hospital today
he has been discharged the disease he
had was tuberculosis the man's name is
Edward R Evans and the woman getting out
of the car to meet him is his wife
Martha for her this has been ten months
three weeks and one day of waiting she
wonders if their marriage will ever be
the same
oh this is the best meal I've had in
months Martha when it comes to pot roast
you are a genius glad you enjoyed it
but tonight all the credit really
belongs to your daughter Dorothy when I
last I remember you wouldn't even set
foot inside the kitchen hated to boil
eggs
that was before took home economics in
school you won't believe it but I like
to cook now will miracles never end hey
Martha still think you can win a game of
Canasta for me Oh we'll find out as soon
as I clear away what if you don't mind
wasn't Johnny coming over to study with
you tonight
oh he he couldn't make it you go on mom
I'll be careful with the glasses
all right there come on mr. Evans I warn
you I've had a lot of time to practice
things are gonna be a lot different from
now on
I guess everything will be different
from now on Johnny knows why dad's been
in the hospital maybe he won't come over
anymore
I'm sure dad's cured not dangerous or
anything but with Johnny understand that
suppose his folks tell him to stop
seeing me maybe I'll even have to quit
school and get a job to help out why why
did this have to happen to us and
when you have much trouble in getting an
office job at the plant why should I
I've been with the Martin company as
long as anybody I know the business
backwards
yes dear but it's Foreman your
experience is all been in the shopping I
want that I know you can't help worrying
about it their savings almost gone and
well I'm sure it hasn't been easy for
you and Dorothy so I can't boss the gang
at the furniture plan but I can still
put in my 8 hour a day and then my
payers as well as anybody else and don't
forget that studying course the hospital
recommend it those hours I put in
studying bookkeeping are gonna come in
mighty handy I may not be a CPA yet but
it's a place to start you'll be all
right dear I know it well of course it
will and let's finish the game it's your
play well will it really be all right
after all this time and all the money
we've had to spend well and we can do is
hope
we're delighted to see you back on your
feet again the TV people said you'd be
released soon they tell me I'm as good
as new
all that spa thing it's a real shame you
can't go back into the shop we really
could use you there well I still know
the furniture business mr. Wilson as
I've told you I've been studying up on
bookkeeping methods in the hospital yes
yes I know I really wish I could do
something for you what do you do in a
case like this I could find a job for
I'm sure well then it's on my shoulders
if anything goes wrong suppose he gets
sick again
suppose this TV is still contagious and
some of the other men get it oh I can't
be responsible for him the trouble is
that we're overloaded on our office
staff now and I have to let somebody
else go to the pit you win you see I
understand I'm sorry ed cups later if
there's an opening well thank you very
much mr. Wilson if you want references
or anything like that I'll be glad to
get into you anytime it's very kind of
you thanks a lot good luck
so far so good mr. Evans
well I think that gives me a pretty
complete picture of your employment
background unfortunately I don't have
anything your line right at the moment
however I'll certainly keep your
application on file and if anything does
come in I see thank you very much
what's the use I'd fill them out and
they'd fire Thank You mr. Evans we'll
call you if something comes up something
doesn't come up soon Martha I don't know
what we're gonna do I wish I knew what
to tell you it but you've just got to
keep trying yeah well maybe this will be
the lucky one
we've been doing business with a Martin
furniture company for a good many years
anybody with them as long as you work
comes pretty highly recommended glad to
hear it sir
besides I appreciate what you're up
against learning something new starting
all over again had to do with myself
about 15 years ago let's stop in here a
minute I'll introduce you to the man
you'll be working under oh by the way I
don't see any real reason for telling
any of the boys in here what you've been
doing the last year to you no not if you
don't miss a barony good bill me neither
yeah this is bill key how you doing wow
he's in charge of the department and
you'll be working directly under it yeah
nice to meet you mr. Evans
yeah say don't I know you from somewhere
and Evans why sure you used to belong to
our Legion Post of course I remember you
too you were let the drill team one year
that's right say I haven't seen you
around for a while must be almost a year
have you been out of town bill you can
introduce ed to the rest of the boys a
little later right now I want to take
him around and shorten the rest of our
place fine mr. Barrett II see you later
Evans all right
and Evans there's something else
connected with that name sure I remember
the Legion Post selling flowers in the
hospital she had tuberculosis and now he
figures to sit at the desk next to mine
listen fellas I don't know how you feel
about it but personally I think we've
got a little problem here that fellow
that just left with mr. Verity I don't
understand you in mr. Barrett he told
you the job was yours just because his
fellow recognized you from the Legion I
told you it wasn't that monitor he
should have seen the look on his face
and I remember that look often enough
these past few months I could tell what
he was thinking he remembered that I was
in the hospital and why and please
you're just getting yourself all worked
up suppose we take in a movie after
dinner don't we ever go out with our old
friends anymore
I thought you were gonna call Bill and
Jane this morning well I did but but
Jane said their boy was down with a cold
I wouldn't believe it if I read it in a
book in this day and age what are you
talking about it
the Warrens last week Joe and Betsy
Kimmel the week before a remarkable
number of our so-called friends seem to
be seeing less and less of us since I've
been home from the hospital and you're
just adding up things that don't exist
and I nobody's really come out and said
so but people aren't afraid of me Martha
but they told you at the hospital there
there'd be a certain number of people
who would always be hey you're still
here I thought you were going out
tonight you said you were going to be
ours
it's been called off does it make any
difference no only I invited Johnny and
so the gang over a little later but I
can still feel it a minute Dorothy what
are you going to phone him about well if
you're staying home I thought we better
go to Johnny's house so one of the other
kids well you don't have to do that we
don't mind having him over
how can I tell them that I don't want to
ask the gang over I'm afraid they won't
come because dad you don't want them to
come over because of me
Davi I can remember when your friend
used to swarm all over this house your
older dad not the same wouldn't you
remember no it's Johnny I keep hearing
about I've never met him yet Dante are
you afraid that you might get sick my
cat's tuberculosis because of me
No then you know that I wouldn't have
been released if there was a slightest
chance I know it but some of my friends
don't then why don't you tell him I
tried to it first but we got into an
argument and I was afraid they wouldn't
believe me anyway after that I made up
my mind or worried the whole subject and
as long as they didn't come over while
you were here I didn't know what else to
do
yeah I understand believe me I do and
I'm sorry I haven't tried to help you on
your problems before but you see now
that avoiding the subject is really no
answer at all don't you then why don't
you upstairs and fix up your face and
when your friends come if there are any
arguments to be settled at all maybe I
can sort of act as referee alright don't
you worry about me hopefully now okay
you know it that was awfully good advice
you gave Dorothy I'm just wondering if
you shouldn't try some of your own
medicine on that Keating fellow at the
lumber company that's funny I was just
thinking the same thing
that's about all I can say I completely
cure as a matter of fact I really safer
to be near than you are because I have
to keep
back to the hospital for my regular
checkups there's absolutely no danger of
infection my doctors told mr. verrity
that except for the fact that I need
more arrests than most people I'm no
different than that idea
bill Keating will you ever learn where
you were all ready to strike out a man
before he ever got a chance to go to bed
and why because you didn't stop to think
you listen to rumors and jump to
conclusions
that's why Evans I think I owe you an
apology I didn't have all the facts
straight but I do now
and as far as I'm concerned I'll see
that you get every break possible why
not asking for any special breaks just a
fair chance that's all and Ed Evans got
his fair chance and made the most of it
despite the handicap of his late start
in the accounting business and makes
good at his job and becomes well-liked
by his fellow employees and his employer
the Evans home once more becomes a
popular meeting place for all of
Dorothy's young friends and Johnny in
particular
Dorothy's fears that she might have to
leave school and help support the family
have been dispelled and things seem to
be working out well on all fronts but
through his new acquaintances
Ed's friendships soon begin to multiply
and before long most of his former
friends also begin to drift back once
more
ed is able to relax and enjoy himself
knowing that he has fought his way back
again able to face the future with a
full measure of confidence
returning to the hospital for his
regular examination ed Evans can report
that he has been fully
in employment friendship and family
unfortunately it has taken too long a
time unfortunately it had been hard on
end and his family needlessly Ed's
former employer lost a valuable worker a
lack of knowledge understanding and
faith has caused these unnecessary
losses that has been ed Evans story will
this man's be the same
his name is Richard Newton and he has
spent nine months one week in four days
in this hospital today he has been
discharged the disease he had was
tuberculosis the decision as to what
happens to his future whether he will be
received back into an active full and
worthwhile life by his family his
friends and his employer or whether he
will be shunned and will have to fight
his way back step by step is something
that only one person can say and that
person is you